so welcome to this event which is
celebrating the release of reflections
magazine I think you all have now
received a copy of it a magazine that in
this issue is being used to address the
issue of the millennium development
goals and the timing is not accidental
as you know there's a UN summit going on
for the Millennium Development Goals and
President Obama i am told made a very
important speech on that today so this
is a very timely conversation timely
because the problems of poverty that the
millennium development goals are
designed to address are significant we
have in this country according to the
latest census data 43.6 million or one
in seven Americans who live in poverty
we have on the global scene 2.6 billion
people who live on less than two dollars
a day despite all the advances of the
last decade since the millennium
development goals were first announced
and first embraced we still have issues
to address it's a time I think to take
action a time to be very serious about
addressing these goals Nelson Mandela
was quoted in the New York Times by Bono
very recently saying sometimes it falls
upon a nation to be great I think it
falls on our United Nations to be great
and to address these issues these issues
have always been of concern to people of
faith and one of the things that we hope
to do through this issue of reflections
and through this distinguished panel
tonight is to help faith communities in
addressing these issues hence there are
no more excuses it's time to take action
on those millennium development goals
and to address poverty in a very serious
way we're going to go around and I'm
going to introduce members of the panel
and ask each a question and there's one
panelist who is delayed and should be
here before the end of our session will
give her an opportunity to to
participate but let me begin with
Abigail Nelson a senior vice president
Episcopal of relief and development in
New York an Episcopal Church agency that
works in more than four
countries Abigail has given us a
remarkable reflection in this issue of
reflections a meditation on the many
forms that poverty takes Abigail in your
aid work you've seen some unimaginable
conditions and some inspirational
successes in your view what kinds of
approaches to poverty work best what
will it take for the world to eliminate
poverty well thank you for inviting me
to be part of this panel today and for
honoring my reflection and for asking me
to contribute to this particular issue
of reflections in response to your
questions for me the greatest challenge
and the greatest opportunity is to put
the most vulnerable of us at the center
of our program work at the center of
everything that we do when I think about
some of the the trips I've taken some of
the conversations I've had some of the
people who speak to me and through me to
us and through us to the world I think
of a woman who lived in a shack made of
four pieces of corrugated tin and with
caring for her two children in the
middle of a of a geographic area that
was about to be bulldozed by the
building of a road one might say that it
was progress that that road was going in
and could potentially linked the others
in the community to greater access
provide greater access to markets for
those people things they moved back and
forth over that road and for this
particular woman the capacity that she
had to lean together those four walls
and provide a little bit of shelter for
her two children and the great risk that
she was under because that road was
going in spoke to me about the
challenges of addressing development of
addressing the people who are at the
centre of any program that we look at in
terms of moving forward with the
development and her voice is the voice
that we all have to hold in front of us
as we deliberate as we consider and as
we look at the resources we put into the
many things that we do thank you very
much keeping the vulnerable at the
center of our attention very important
advice Thomas pogi is the lighter
professor of philosophy and
international affairs at Yale his latest
book is politics as usual what lies
behind the pro-poor rhetoric Thomas
you've given a lot of sustained thought
to the dynamics of poverty and human
rights and you are not terribly
impressed by the efforts of the rich
nations to reduce poverty what realistic
steps should the rich nations take to
improve the lives of the four well I
think the first thing to do is to
recognize the magnitude of the poverty
problem and how we have been concealing
it and miscounting it so just to give
you an example the poverty is defined by
the World Bank in terms of one dollar 25
PPP poverty line in two thousand and
five dollars converted at purchasing
power parity the poverty problem is
roughly one sixth of one percent of
world income so it's a very very small
problem in economic terms and that is
the problem that the world's governments
have committed themselves to eradicate
exactly to eradicate it but to begin
eradicated over a 25-year period so
between 1990 and 2015 you're supposed to
reduce that problem by half not the
number of poor exactly but the
proportion of poor people in the
population of the developing countries
so if you think about that a problem the
magnitude of which is one-sixth of one
percent of world income the sum of all
gross national income and we take 25
years to make a dent into that problem
reduce the number of poor by
twenty-seven percent of the proportion
of poor by fifty percent that's a
ridiculous response and it's a
ridiculous response especially when you
realize how huge the problem is in human
terms roughly 1 in 3 people living in
this earth will die from poverty related
causes about 18 million people a year
nine million children under the edge
five another 9 million people older are
dying from these causes now you spoke
about the efforts in your question and
should be maybe make greater efforts I
would say that what we need to do first
and foremost is do less harm a lot of
the rules that are being imposed at the
global level by governments mainly rich
country governments our kinds of
governments but also with the
collaboration of governments in the
poorer countries many of these rules are
tremendously harmful to poor people and
if we could just get these harms reduced
then we would do a great amount towards
the eradication of poverty we have
oscilla tating corruption we are
protecting our markets against imports
from the poorest of countries in many
different ways that I could multiply we
are harming the global poor and the
income distribution in the world is
shifting against the poor the bottom
quarter of the world's population now
has 0.76 percent of global income of the
world income global household income
that is and that's down by roughly
one-third since 1988 so they're
struggling with the ever-shrinking share
of global income and so it's not
surprising that poverty persists and of
course it's not surprising that the
rules don't reflect the interests of the
poor because the poor are not at the
table when these rules are being
negotiated okay so learning to do less
harm and examining the rules by which we
live Peter Singer is professor of
bioethics at Princeton whose lettuce
book is the life you can save acting now
to end world poverty in reflections
professor singer spells out the ethical
mandate we have for coming to the aid of
poor people across the world and he
calls for a change in our Public ethics
to make this happen so what will it take
to produce a ground swell of reform of
our spending habits so that individuals
and nations have stronger impacts
against poverty and as such reform
realistic and pragmatic thank you um I
think reform is realistic about its
take a lot of hard work and a lot of
action from people involved in the anti
global poverty movement in the book I
talk about some of the psychological
barriers that people have to giving
including for example the problem that
psychologists know as futility thinking
if you think of it as a huge problem and
you say well what difference can I make
how can I make a difference to this very
large number of people 1.4 billion or
whatever it might be living in poverty
but if we get people to focus on
particular things that work and that
achieve success then I think we can
overcome that barrier and there are a
lot of programs that are very effective
I was this morning at a breakfast
organized by Save the Children where I
heard dr. Abe a bang talking about a
program that they've instituted starting
with pilots in remote tribal regions of
India where without using any qualified
doctors just by educating a literate
woman in each village on some fairly
elementary practices and giving her a
minimal amount of equipment they've been
able to reduce the infant mortality rate
from 121 per thousand to 30 per thousand
so you can imagine what that can do in
terms of saving lives if spread across
India and indeed there even now piloting
in Africa but they do need more
resources so we have to get people to
see that that you and you and you or
perhaps a group of you associated with
whatever it might be a church or a
community center or any any group of
people can come together and adopt some
specific project that's making a
difference that's working and I think if
we can encourage people to work together
and to support each other because the
other psychological fact is people are
more likely to give if they know that
others are giving there's a lot more
information I'd love to give out I've
got a website the life you can save calm
please go and take a look at that and
they'll be more about it there too and
thanks for that hand on the website for
finding some practical projects ways to
get involved in the addressing the issue
David Beckman is president of bread for
the world a Christian organization that
urges the nation's decision makers to
end hunger here and abroad
also an economist and Lutheran minister
in recent years we've endured a world
food crisis that increased food prices
and increased world poverty what are the
critical issues specifically related to
food policy that we need to address in
the world produce enough food for
everyone I'm actually really encouraged
that in this case the US government is
as responded to the increase in world
hunger in a remarkably good way the US
government is leading a global
mobilization to help poor farmers in
developing countries increase their own
production just this week Hillary
Clinton put together a big meeting at
the United Nations governments around
the world to help people know that we
have new knowledge about the best ways
to reduce child malnutrition so with
existing dollars we could be making a
bigger impact on the death of death and
disability of children due to
malnutrition so and then I we you know
just an hour before this meeting
President Obama not only made a speech
at the United Nations more importantly
he issued a directive to the whole US
government so for the first time in our
history the US government has a coherent
policy to support economic growth and
poverty reduction in developing
countries and agriculture is one of the
emphasis that he is encouraging the
whole US government to to support so for
people of faith you know it comes back
to us to push I think it's specially
push our members of Congress in this
case the president's doing some good
things but we need to push our own
members of Congress to work with the
president to provide funding for his
world and hunger initiative to work with
the President to make our foreign aid
more effect
given our website is bread org so if
people want to help push Congress on
issues that affect hungry and poor
people in our country around the world
it's bread org or at least that's one
place you can go well thank you for the
next website yeah we'll get a lot of
good links I think out of this Willis
Jenkins you are the Margaret Farley
assistant professor of social ethics at
Yale Divinity School with international
experience and development initiatives
and you're the author of Ecology's of
grace environmental ethics and Christian
theology you call and your reflections
article for a redefinition of real
wealth to include biodiversity and
ecological integrity who will lead the
way in that who will make such a
fundamental reevaluation of wealth
happen can people of faith have a
realistic role in that project well I
think already leading the way are a
number of those people who are
responding to their ecological
vulnerability I'm impressed by how many
projects and communities that are around
the world who are pressing for
environmental justice for environmental
rights or for initiatives and sustaining
community and I think that you know the
some moral from those various
initiatives may be that there are
environmental dimensions of human
dignity sometimes that may be quite
minimal and when a community is
attempting to protect itself from
ecologically mediated harms like toxins
sometimes it's a bit more when a
community is requesting our right to a
sustaining resource like water and but
the most interesting are where there are
communities that are maintaining that
there is a dignity dignity providing
relationship in Access to biodiversity
or to the web of ecological life and
some of the most interesting here have
been the the recent quite outspoken
witness from councils of indigenous
peoples including some Christian
councils of indigenous peoples on
climate justice and their witness there
is that climate-driven degradation
including loss of biodiversity you row
Oates a great treasure of many cultures
and and that that treasure is a sacred
trust to know and respect the earth and
its creatures so when x over when we
suffer biological impoverishment we
suffer more than the erosion of
biological wealth we suffer these these
councils have been saying any rojin of
our own human dignity and so I I suppose
i take heart and interest and ask for
our moral and theological imaginations
to be fired by these by the ecologically
vulnerable and their attempts to I
wouldn't say redefine but recover a
sense of real wealth okay thank you for
especially introducing that ecological
dimension to our conversation Arthur
keys is president of the international
relief and development organization
based in arlington virginia also a UCC
minister and a yts grad arguer leader in
the development world and you have
theological training so my question is
our american people of faith realizing
their potential in the fight against
poverty a church is fully engaged in the
poverty debate and the fate of the
millennium development goals well i
think i would be a little bit careful
with a yield Divinity School forums to
make too many comments about the state
of the church and the faith
organizations but I think theologically
I think we'd have to say no churches are
not fully engaged I don't think there's
any problem with that there's certainly
much more potential I think that my own
personal view is that it's kind of
interesting that a lot of the kind of
mainline mission agencies of our weaker
I believe and they used to be I don't
think we have the spirit of missionary
zeal I guess the previous generations we
have a lot of parrot search
organizations like read through the
world like Catholic Relief Services and
islamic relief etc that are they're
fairly active world vision but i think
the least the faith tradition that I'm
part of is not as actively engaged I
think as it was a generation I think the
opportunity is there it's kind of
interesting that there are a lot of
major agencies like say the children was
mentioned the the president of
international rescue committee is the
white es graduate george r up i'm a wide
es graduate international release from
development and our website of course is
ir d dot org and Neil Kenny Guyer was on
the EO corporation as a man of faith
heads up Mercy Corps I think there's a
great opportunity for church agencies to
link with some of the non-sectarian
agencies to have greater impact I think
you know this is a classic religious
issue how do you Minister do you
administer 121 you administer car
negation the congregation we certainly
pastors have a lot of experience in that
and what a lot of congregations are
linked up for instance with
congregations in Haiti but my analysis
will be if you want to have a large
impact on large social problems like the
Millennium Challenge goals you have to
deal with larger scale programs and you
have to deal with government funds and
governments have to be part of the
solution so I think that perhaps the
some of the large NGOs could be a link
between the faith communities and the
larger agencies like and also some of
the UN agencies like UNICEF okay
interesting suggestions about the
linking function of NGOs will probably
come back to that as we think about the
practicality of addressing things
through our government connections
christiana peppered you're a yale PhD
candidate focusing on the fate of fresh
water in an era of globalization now you
also have an MA are from IDs so how have
issues of water and poverty changed or
sharpened your own sense of occasion the
first thing to say is that I don't have
a website but I am speaking about
networks in a sense so forgive the pun
water undergirds everything that's the
beginning in the end
of the work that I do gender equity
child mortality economic development
health local agricultural practices
basic survival to name only a few all of
these rely on the availability of clean
fresh water and its counterpart
sanitation the reverse is also true
these things shape water how we govern
how we grow our food what kind and where
how we facilitate or block economic
exchange how we communicate with whom to
what ends how we consume and so on
unfortunately we too often fail to see
these kinds of connections so think of
poverty in terms of freshwater what if
you don't have it here poverty is a lack
it's an absence an absence that shapes
lives if you don't have water you will
spend most of your day trying to get it
or sending someone else to get it for
you control of bodies fresh water
reminds us in ways that gross domestic
product or per capita income do not that
thirst and hunger and strife are written
on us they are written on bodies and
these are moral issues of course so I
would say Harry to your question that
exploring these kinds of connections is
my vocation thus far I ask questions
like what are we beginning to see that
we have not before seen and why not what
has obscured our vision why do
pernicious paradigms persist are their
constructive alternatives none of this
is simple water is never ever ever
simple but it is basic and it is
essential so I think of my work in this
realm as the ongoing challenge of
discernment and perhaps that's a
pragmatists hope but Varun is the
challenge and the vocation
so getting the eyes to see the problems
that are in front of us and opening up
to the possibilities an important part
of what we all should be doing Debbie
MacLeod Sears your recent white es
Grande a wife and mother in Houston
Texas who also has much experience
abroad and doing work with the poor
weather in orphanages or in other
initiatives in reflections you candidly
Chronicle your own evolving perspective
on how to bear witness to the issue of
poverty what do you see now is the best
strategy for reducing global poverty and
what advice do you offer other lay
people who might feel overwhelmed by the
scope of poverty but want to do
something about it the best strategy to
reduce or end poverty is not always
completely financially sustainable the
word is thrown around a lot with regards
to poverty reduction as if it is
essential it is not donors can be and
should be used ease poverty-related
suffering and support individual agency
along with bottom-up programs the best
strategy to reduce or end poverty is
always multi focused there is no one
answer a good example is the founding
and functioning of great schools in the
developing world a good school may be
financed by a micro loan or a small
business loan which is accompanied by
business and education training a well
maybe Doug to provide water for the
school and to sell the water to the
community to help maintain the well as
well as the school breakfast and lunch
may be served to put children and
including Earthcare in your curriculum
also finishes the multi-faceted effect
any effective poverty reduction program
must include equipping and empowering
all to question authority and to use
critical thinking skills to question
government abuses and their current
social order I long to see billboards in
a developing world that read question
authority rather than advertised skin
bleaching cream most paid employee
NGOs were lay persons at one time so
don't underestimate your value just
because you aren't paid actually not
being paid gives you more of an ability
to speak truth to power because you
don't have a boss to answer to eunice
kennedy shriver was a lay person when
she helped found the Special Olympics
the more you learn about poverty and
suffering the more overwhelmed you will
be if you have a brain and a heart the
areas of my life that have been most
personally transformative where the
areas in which I felt initially
ill-equipped I believe that we are
hard-wired by God or service giving
money to a soup kitchen kitchen will
never replace making the soup getting to
know two volunteers and the diners and
doing the dishes when you are finished I
have a website grant me the wisdom
goregaon calm which is empty so don't go
there but at some point there will be
something there okay thank you the
importance of multi focused approaches
to solving poverty and the importance of
critical analysis and engaging what some
of the causes of poverty are Melinda st.
Louis is deputy director of Jubilee USA
an alliance of 75 denominations and
other groups that work for cancellation
of debt for poor nations that Melinda
you make the case that debt forgiveness
of poor nations makes a difference does
it work is dip forgiveness now one of
the world's respected weapons in the
fight against poverty or is it still
controversial and does it meet
resistance well I also am very humbled
to be on this panel with everyone else
debt cancellation is actually and I
believe an example of a success of
faith-based organizing of this was in
the mid 90s faith groups came together
to say we really need to address not
only giving aid to countries but also
address the flow out of those countries
in in the form of debt payments to rich
nations and debt cancellation has been
an important tool to fight poverty it
adds poverty reduction expenditures by
subtraction by subtracting the amount
that's coming out of those countries and
we now have a ten year track record we
were successful in convincing world
leaders to make some really important
commit political commitments in 1999 and
then 2005 and now we've seen some
positive results if for example in
Tanzania there were at one point to 1.5
million children that were able to go to
school after they received debt
cancellation and Ghana they were able to
build 2268 new classrooms 36 new health
clinics for example and in Africa for
every debt relief dollar they've
received they've been able to invest two
dollars in social spending so this has
been a very important tool and it's also
helped countries create the political
policy space they needed during the
economic crisis some of some were
actually able to increase social
spending when they wouldn't have been
able to if that money had been tied up
in debt payments but and when we started
talking about debt cancellation it was
completely off the table was told we
were told it couldn't be done and David
Beckman was very much a part of that of
that initial that initial movement but
now world leaders actually hold up their
role in the multilateral debt relief
initiative as a form of pride this is
something that we have done we were told
they couldn't do it before and then
after faith leaders organized they
agreed that that they could and they
have done it but it is an unfinished
agenda there are still many countries
there are 20 countries that are very
poor that were completely left out of
debt relief deals and some of the
underlying structures that were that
hell were not changed underlying
structures that of conditions that were
placed on loans and debt relief and and
the fact that irresponsible lending and
borrowing has continued so we want to
continue that but in terms of whether it
is still controversial I think there are
pieces of it that are the
when we begin to talk about the
legitimacy of the debts actually holding
lenders responsible also for making bad
loans two of two countries that they
don't really want to talk so much about
that so we need to continue to push push
that agenda but generally it has been
something that is recognized as as as
important for fighting poverty okay
thank you very much we've been joined
now by Katherine Marshall welcome
Catherine is a senior fellow at the
Georgetown University's Berkeley Santa
for religion peace and world affairs and
director of world faiths development
dialogue and this after many years with
the World Bank and much experience and
development issues in reflections you
identify the areas trends that suggests
we've arrived at a historic moment a
realization that poverty elimination is
now a reachable dream as well as an
ethical imperative what gives you hope
that we can stay on the task and keep
our resolve despite all the politics and
inertia and bad bad news the most
extraordinary progress has been made in
our lifetimes in seeing a dramatic
change in the lives of billions of
people and what that shows is what can
be done even in my own professional
career I remember these stories of the
reports the technical reports on the
hopelessness of countries like Singapore
and Ireland which were seen as countries
which could never go anywhere we've seen
how dramatically and how quickly the
fate of Nations can change and in the
difficult world of statistics we see the
dramatic increase in lifespan the
reductions and infant mortality so we
know that it can be done we also know
and it doesn't take very much many
people have pointed out how much money
was mobilized how quickly for the
stimulus plan how much is spent on
military budgets tiny fractions of those
resources if they were well applied
could bring an end to the worst forms of
poverty so we have this situation of
knowing that it can be done knowing that
we have the resources and that I think
gives an imperative which we've never
had in human history because through
most of human history poverty was
inevitable it was a part of life most
people were poor and now we know that
that's different it doesn't make it
easier it doesn't educating one child is
hard enough educating the world's
children is an enormous challenge
reducing maternal mortality ending
disease nothing is simply a stroke of
the pen or a speech or an act of will
that requires the kind of organization
and passion and commitment that that
we've seen in some instances but the
fact is that there is a commitment
that's the historic commitment of the
millennium declaration in the year 2000
the sincere effort to bring the best
tools that we have of discipline of
accounting of accountability of
deadlines of measurement of the of
standards so we have really a historic
engagement a historic promise and and
that I think is grounds for enormous
hope like to follow up with a question
that'll be directed to the whole of the
panel I'd like you to perhaps give us
the first response to it what we've
heard so far is yes messages of Hope a
call for some critical analysis and
analysis of what
do harm a call to raise our
consciousness and to be focused on those
who are most vulnerable a call to find
practical ways of getting involved in
specific circumstances and projects to
relieve poverty and also a call to lobby
either directly or indirectly and
through organizations devoted to poverty
relief ban ki-moon and they opening to
the summit said we should not balance
the budgets on the backs of the poor we
must not draw back from official
development assistance a lifeline of
billions for billions so the question
that I have now is can we be optimistic
or pessimistic that we can make
significant progress on the millennium
development goals in the next five years
the goal is to reach certain levels by
2015 what are the obstacles to reaching
those goals and how do we address them
Africa to begin and anybody else can
then chimed in to be the goal of ending
the worst forms of poverty of misery of
people going to bed hungry of deaths
that couldn't easily be prevented
maternal mortality 2,000 times in nazare
what it is in Europe it's morally not
only straight forward I think it's
morally absolutely compelling so there's
there is the at least a moral clarity
there those of us who've worked in the
development field know very well that it
is very complicated if it were simply a
question of mobilizing and directing
money that would in some senses be an
easy task requires a sensitive
thoughtful determined organized effort
to to mobilize the resources of
countries and the passion and the
commitment of the people concerned as
well as those who have the resources
and one of the things that I find
troubling in this is not that there is
debate because debate is what we should
be doing we should have an active
exchange about what works learning the
lessons of the past but the lack of
engagement and I'd be very interested in
hearing other members of the panel that
there is a sort of a sound by culture
that that there has to be a simple
answer that one one problem can detract
from that so I think we need to find a
way and I think this is one of my hopes
for the kind of engagement with the
broad-based religious community that
that is driven by the ethical concerns
that that we can find better ways to
debate whether microcredit is truly more
important than nutrition supplements or
what is the best way to deal with the
problems of education at that
disagreement is an important part of the
process but that it should not paralyze
us so I think that's that's the
challenge that we have in the next not
only in the next five years and I think
we also need to dream bigger because
2015 is not the end 2015 in a sense is
simply a marker and I'm hopeful that we
can see enough clarity and have enough
engagement intellectual and practical
that we can truly find ways to to look
beyond
I mean my sense is if you combine the
fire of the idea which everybody who
came here tonight and everyone who's
devoted their life work to engaging
which is that we can end world poverty
so there's the fire of this emotional
idea with all of the statistics
intellectual discussion I know zillions
of papers and speeches that are out
there you can build alliances with those
who are like-minded we can do a great
deal and I think you know you you just
shared over the past generation many
things that have happened when we think
of Singapore we think of Ireland to
think of Vietnam you think of what's
happened in China I mean which has
lifted a billion people out of poverty
in one country alone by change and you
can you say to yourself well what can
happen over the next five years I mean I
review what's happened over the past
five when it's come to the malaria
prevention discussion I mean any of us
here involved in public health think
about what's happened in terms of
building alliances with roll back
malaria between the faith communities
and the corporate communities and
governments and we've been able to
effect huge amounts of change just over
the past month the largest net
distribution and hanging program in
history happened in Ghana and the faith
community the Anglican Church of Ghana
was at the center of that so I I truly
believe that the faith community is
critical I believe each each and every
one of us in the pews and in these fora
are critical again I what I really
believe is that we need to lift the
visibility up about the good things that
are happening and create positive
energies that people want to join and be
part of and in just as much in our
statistical analysis of what are the
critical problems we address statistical
analysis and we lift up the stories of
what are actually extraordinary
successes that are happening out there
otherwise we all just feel tremendously
depressed and fill up our tents and go
mow David I'm just profoundly hopeful
because hundreds of millions of people
have escaped from extreme poverty over
the last 20 years we've more could have
happened more could be done but this is
an extraordinary liberation and for
you know when I look at that what's
happened and I believe in God this is
God moving in our history this is our
loving God answering the prayers of
hundreds of millions of people it mostly
you know the work is being done by those
people for their kids but the fact that
we have seen countries like Bangladesh
and Ethiopia and Ghana Brazil Britain
reduced poverty this to me this is this
is the great this the liberation that is
taking place that can take place from
poverty is the great exodus of our time
it makes what happened at the Red Sea
look like small potatoes it is huge and
in our own country the reason why
Americans don't get it is because in our
own country we cut poverty in half in
the 60s and early 70s but since then we
have not achieved sustained progress
against poverty but if Bangladesh and
Britain can do it do we think it's not
possible in the USA of course it's
possible and I think God is longing to
realize the liberation that's so clearly
possible and that its people of God's
calling people of faith to get off the
couch and partly to change politics as
usual so all there are lots of different
ways for us to be involved but we're not
going to see the progress against
poverty and hunger that's possible if we
don't change politics as usual
well I also am hopeful but to be a bit
provocative I also might sound a little
bit like a wet blanket here because I
also while I think that the millennium
development goals can be achieved I
think we can cut extreme poverty I think
that we have it in our power if we
organize I think that this summit that
happened here the last three days was
not the breakthrough plan that was
needed I am I was disappointed because I
felt that that there were there were a
lot of important statements that were
made recognitions of past promises I
think it's important that the millennium
development goals are still on the table
after 10 years and that people know what
they are but there weren't there weren't
concrete commitments that were made I in
my opinion there were there in terms of
for especially for the developed world
to to recognize that there has been
progress made but there was a financial
crisis that started on wall street that
had repercussions across the entire
world and that that the progress that
was made a lot of it has gone backwards
because of the food crisis because of
the fuel crisis and because of this
financial crisis and the and the climate
crisis that is growing and that the
developed countries took up
disproportionate atmospheric space over
many years and contributed to climate
change and it's the poor that are
feeling the effects of that and and I
didn't see the urgency from world
leaders to to really make that take that
next step and and to and to pay back the
debt that are that developed countries
02 to the world's poor and so so to me
it's a galvanizing call of you know we
are able to to organize we've made great
change but I in order to feel optimistic
we need to really hold our elected
leaders feet to the fire on
and we and it's not going to happen with
it without that yeah i'm also on the wet
blanket team I'm sorry to say and first
reality check the fao the food and
agriculture organization of the united
nations announced in 2009 that for the
first time in all of human history there
were more than a billion people
chronically undernourished that's
reliable information that's interesting
so there hasn't been at the global level
a lot of progress we are now down to
nine hundred and twenty five million as
they announced a few days ago so that's
progress but basically in all the years
from the 90 s 2 2009 there was rising
poverty as measured in terms of chronic
under nutrition or at least it was flat
but basically a rising tendency was
around 800 million in the 1990s the
World Bank presents positive statistics
Rosie statistics about the number of
pool going down and a half of my book is
about how these numbers are manufactured
and you better read that before you are
too optimistic and at least get the
other side of the story one thing that I
can tell you is that according to the
World Bank's own numbers if you take a
reasonable poverty line of two dot 50
per person per and more reasonable it's
not still not sufficient to meet human
needs but if you take the two dollar
fifty poverty line you find that even
according to the World Bank statistics
poverty has gone up the number of two
people has gone up since 1990 so I think
don't look at these complicated
convoluted PvP calculations look at how
many people are hungry and you'll get a
good sense of what's happening on the
ground with regard to poverty one more
point if I may and that is this there
are millions of success stories so I
agree with what you are all set there
are many many people doing good work
thousands and thousands of NGOs
thousands of good stories of progress
and the remarkable thing is that things
are getting worse despite all these
successes
so there are much larger forces at work
against the poor than all these
wonderful good forces in favor of the
poor I want to give you one example of
the forces that I'd work against the
poor you know how much development aid
goes into the poor countries every year
it's about 120 billion dollars of that
fifteen point five billion dollars goes
for basic social services that is to say
goes for basic needs of people the rest
goes for all sorts of other stuff more
of interest to rich exporters or rich
elites in the developing countries than
to poor people but do you know how much
money flows out of poor countries
illicitly about a trillion dollars a
thousand billion dollars Dwarfs all
development assistance how does that
flow out well in many ways but here to
the most important the first is
embezzlement officials in poor countries
steal a lot of money not just people at
the very top but all the way down and
they Park it into bank accounts in the
West including this country a lot of it
goes to this country into secret
personal bank accounts in the United
States when you come and you've stolen
money and your bank knows that is
perfectly legal for the bank to accept
that money and so it is in many other
most other Western countries if you make
your money with drugs you can't deposit
if you make your money right with with
drugs you can't deposit the money if you
do it with terrorist activities you
can't deposit the money these are the
two exceptions where banks after we wary
but if you make your money trafficking
children or stealing from your home
government or something like that your
money is welcome here it's welcome in
Switzerland welcome and Germany welcome
in the cayman islands bermuda and so on
and so forth so that's a lot of money
flowing out another even larger chunk of
money flows out through text avoidance
schemes where corporations miss price
trade within the corporation or within
their subsidiaries where they for
example produce something in india salad
in south africa just a random example
they sell it cheaply to their subsidiary
in the cayman islands so sorry there's
no
in India then they sell it expensively
from the Cayman Islands to South Africa
so sorry there's no profit in South
Africa but there's a lot of profit in
the Cayman Islands why it's only a guy
with the telephone the goods never go
there nobody ever produces anything
there sells it there why is there a lot
of profit there but that's where the tax
rates are lowest so again hundreds of
billions of dollars are lost to poor
countries through these shenanigans of
corporations there is a lot of good work
billions of dollars worth tens of
billions of dollars worth there is a lot
of progress stories very good project he
a good project there but all that good
work is blowing against a tornado a much
stronger head win against the poor so
the point that I'm making is not poverty
eradication when you think about the
voiding poverty it's not a matter of
doing a lot to eradicate poverty but a
lot is being done to keep the poor poor
and that we have to understand that if
they went this enormous head wind
against the poor then they would rise
along with the average income in the
world at the pace and poverty would long
have gone the poor are not yet
participating proportionately in global
economic growth in a 17 year period they
lost fully one-third of their share of
global household consumption income in a
global household income ok I think we'll
have to take that as a good warning and
some of the other things that we need to
be paying attention to and the forces
that working against the poor to over on
this side Christy pepper at nana keys
Christy I think that one of the
theological insights brought to this
kind of discussion is that there are
always multiply nuanced realities hope
and despair good and evil no one thing
is ever entirely one or the other and it
sometimes helps me to keep this in mind
when thinking about problems of global
poverty pardon me and the suffering that
people endure in those kinds of contexts
dr. pogi has a great line
he referenced which is making headway
into headwinds which i think is a very
important image because yes there is
progress but what are the forces running
against us as well and this is something
that as an ethicist as someone who
thinks about morality and action and
responsibilities under conditions of
globalization especially economic
globalization that we have to take
really really seriously again quoting
dr. pogi and I promise we have never met
before actually so this is a great
delight for me but and he points out
that contributing to this situation are
choices individual choices choices scale
it up a level policies of states and so
forth and also global economic
institutions and structures all of these
things shape the way that wealth and
power and ability and access our
navigated under conditions of
globalization and that to me poses
significant questions of moral
responsibility of complicity of who we
are and how we act for the greater good
so to melinda's point yes we need to
organize but what then does effective
collective action look like it's not
merely charity though that's important
it's not merely lobbying your
legislators though that too is important
it also includes taking a deep deep look
at these institutions and by
institutions I mean arrangements of
political economy that permeate the
global context in the present day to see
how power wealth money all these things
flow and with what kinds of predictable
consequences how we throw a cog in those
that's a big question okay and what a
challenge art I always try to avoid
beating you the optimist or a pessimist
and try to think of myself as a realist
but I think one major issue that hasn't
been put on the table here and that's
the politics a major constraint here of
economic progress
is political conflict and particularly
wide scale war some of us are old enough
to remember the stories of World Wars of
tens of millions of people being killed
of tens of millions of people being
refugees many people in this room i'm
sure we're affected by that i spent a
lot of my professional life in bosnia my
wife's family from bosnia and i can tell
you civil society can snap overnight and
social upheaval religious conflict what
achill conflict can come out overnight
so i think if we're like thinking about
the next five years of making progress
on the Millennium Challenge goals we
have to know if there's going to be a
major warfare and is it going to be a
political break down here Sudan is a
good example of everything is in the in
the balance that country could have
tremendous economic growth and
development if there is no warfare and
if churches play a positive and
religious institutions are positive and
not a negative role and but I think the
question is is there and it's not clear
which way it's going to go okay we're
coming close to the end of our time for
formal interaction and I know the panel
would like to have some time to chat
with you individually and perhaps to get
a glass of wine but what I want to do is
to have everybody on the panel have one
final word so 30 second sound bite and
we'll start at this end so what what
should we take away well for me I would
say that that the millennium development
goals are an important tool but when
we're talking about poverty to me we
need to move beyond specific goals and
benchmarks and actually start talking
about economic justice and that and that
that piece is is extraordinarily
important I think that as long as the
structures exist that for example that
created the financial crisis I think
that was a clarion call that we have a
limited earth we have limited resources
and we cannot continue a casino type a
way of just profits profits profits
profits over people
and that we need to actually change
those structures and if we're really
going to address poverty and and really
build up of human dignity Debbie I
believe there are two areas that are
being ignored most NGOs focus on
children's education which is millennium
development goal number two but in Ghana
parents ask for evening evening literacy
classes in their children's school they
will be much better parents and can much
more easily question authority if they
are literate what needs to be said is
that I believe that Muhammad Yunus was
wrong when he said the poor only need a
loan to work their way out of poverty
microloan efficacy has recently become
the subject of much academic research
which is showing that long-term
transformation may not be statistically
significant for most followers we have
been unable to find any academic study
that shows that microfinance without
education has any long-term effect in
raising the poor above a subsistence
level like any business owner the poor
need to be literate have financial and
business skill training and most
importantly be able to use critical
thinking skills to make assessments what
needs to be said by the church about
poverty is that being that is not being
said is that God does not intend for
poverty and suffering to exist and it
accomplishes nothing in God's plan
Christ spent a great deal of time
according to the Gospels healing the
sick and feeding the hungry people
suffer all over the world because of
choices that rich and middle class
Americans make every day to give you an
example every time you buy bottled water
rather than using a platypus which is
what I use my new year's resolution was
to not buy bottled water this folds up
and I keep it in my purse and I never
kept buy bottled water you are
supporting large international water
companies who go into the developing
world
water at rock bottom prices while the
citizens in those developing countries
pay much higher inflated prices you
every time you buy a bottle of water are
doing that you individually not somebody
else what is not being said is that the
disconnect between what Americans do and
what happens to the poor must be exposed
and ended ok thank you Christy I have
two points the first can be summarized
is everything connects to everything
else but that doesn't mean we should
just give up more formally negative
feedback cycles in global economic
arrangements need a lot more attention
particularly how arrangements of
political economy the way our societies
and our modes of exchange and governance
are structured how those interact with
environmental realities and specifically
environmental resource degradation
because as Willis and and others and I
have pointed to without some kind of
environmental integrity you don't have
much you spend your life just trying to
survive on a very desiccated land for
example so how arrangements of political
economy environmental factors and
poverty mutually interrelate and what
can be done about those the second point
is a bit more of a moral theory sort of
theological idea and that's moral
responsibility in a complex world so dr.
singer and pogi have written quite
elegantly and importantly about
questions of harm and responsibility
they are among the very few to do so in
a way that is captured in journalism as
being thought leaders so if these
questions are easier for us to shirk
because they're hugely uncomfortable
right who likes to be told by debi that
we are impacting people in in other
countries negatively what every time we
buy bottled water incidentally I agree
so but the point is basic that economic
globalization raises these huge
questions because the realities are not
just out there it's not just a problem
of corrupt governments though that can
also be a contributing factor these
realities refract back onto us they
shape us so these are questions of
responsibility they are also questions
of ontology of who we understand
ourselves to be and who we are and that
does not get enough of a hearing thanks
hey thank you all right I think one of
the questions which is often left out of
the debate on the MDGs is the fact that
I believe that we have to do development
in conflict zones I think that people
often look at this chronologically that
you have peace and then you do have
development but I think the world is
more complex than that so I believe you
have to have development as you're
working towards peace people if your
mandate is to deal with the least of
these the least of these are people who
are caught up through often though fault
of their own in conflict areas so I
think that's a real challenge for us to
do if we want to get our hands dirty and
really get into the fray I'll give you
an example my organization justice last
year distributed 1 million tree saplings
to farmers in southern Afghanistan and
Helmand and Kandahar province with his
active warfare going on but what
happened there these farmers got back
into production they produced food they
produced cash they received tractors for
their coops they receive fertilizer the
refuted receive pruning equipment which
increased the pomegranate crop
tremendously and when they got a stake
into into their being able to control
their own lives again they pushed back
the Taliban and they got beyond the
conflict areas and got back into
someone's of
a more normal society so I think that's
a big thing that we have to do and you
know I think the challenge of us as
development professionals and religious
people if we're going to make a serious
dent on the millennium development goals
we have to be involved in nation
building I know that's a politically
kind of charged comment but I'll expose
myself as a closet Calvinist I think
religion is about building nations and
religion is a building block of but but
my plea is the religion teach tolerance
teach the value of all people and teach
allow people to live in harmony with
differences Willis right and then my my
response to your opening question I I
pointed out that there are in
environmental dimensions of human
development and and I would have
elaborated that I think that there are
rich resources within Christian
traditions for for developing those
connections at the very least we might
say that the the poor will not be
blessed if they inherit the kingdom of
God without the creatures of God or the
meek will not be blessed if they inherit
a devastated earth and I think that
there are there are there wonderful ego
theological resources and they're
they're great communities doing make
things just a day churches in the United
Kingdom we're ringing their bells for
biodiversity and I think what I want to
say is that those bells toll not only
for the creatures that are being lost
but for our own souls as well but I want
to leave you with a slightly different
final point and that is that our
responses to human poverty are in an era
of massive human power over the earth
also de facto and ecological management
plan like it or not how we respond to
poverty is reshaping the earth and that
means that we have to respond to poverty
and imaginative and beautiful and
creative ways I'm not just delivering
packets of resources and calories right
which is to say that they're not just
environmental dimensions of human
development but that human development
is quickly becoming the environment for
all humans and all of the creatures well
my summing up would be that God's
calling us to change the politics of
poverty there are the issues that we've
been discussing here tonight are all
being discussed in the US Congress this
is you know this is not these are real
choices that our country is making right
now there are really important issues
for poor people in this country for poor
people around the world that are being
decided by the US Congress now so you
know this is not an academic exercise
relatively small groups of people can
change the politics the United States
and in that process reduce poverty in
our country and reduce poverty around
the world this is an election year so
it's not only advocacy for who's sitting
in Congress but everybody who hears this
should just do one thing different to
get a candidate elected to Congress who
gives a damn about poverty just God
doesn't need us to do everything just
take one step to change the elections of
November for poor people and you know I
think I think God can can use people of
faith to turn the direction of the world
and open up lots of opportunity for poor
people in our country and all over the
world thank you thank you well since I'm
addressing an audience from a divinity
school which is not my my usual
territory let me say that I think the
religious institutions and perhaps the
Christian churches in particular have
really failed to convey a serious
ethical message which I would take to be
as I read the Gospels and the principal
method message on them which is that
really if you're not doing something
substantial for the poor you're not
living in ethical life and I find a huge
amount of complacence in the United
States and among Christians to
that they think that if they just don't
do certain things and if they vote the
right way on some issues then they're
nice decent ethical people I think
that's what needs to change I think we
really need to get people to see both
that they're contributing perhaps to the
sort of harms that Thomas has been
talking about in various ways and I'll
add the climate change one to that too
but also that you know we can share it's
no huge sacrifice to give five or ten
percent of our income at least two
organizations that are fighting poverty
and if we did that and we chose
effective organizations to give to it
would make a huge difference to hundreds
of millions of people and I'm not sure
why that message is not really being put
forward a lot more forcefully than it is
unless it's just that Christians like
anyone else are comfortable living a
luxurious life and they're happy to go
on doing that and never mind what the
ethics of it really seriously are yeah
so I make two points first I think what
we need very urgently is an honest
accounting of how many poor people there
are and what our goal is with regard to
those people we've promised to half
poverty by 2015 three times the first
time we've said we are half the number
of hungry and poor people between 1996
and 2015 that was the World Food Summit
in Rome the second time in the
millennium declaration we said we half
the percentage of poor people in world
population between 2000 and 2015 the
third time in the first millennium in
the minimum Development Goals we
backdated to the baseline of 1990 and
said we will have the proportion of poor
people in the population of the
developing countries between 1990 and
2015 now you won't be able to remember
that but he is what you can remember how
many poor people extremely poor people
are morally acceptable in the Year 2015
according to the first promise 828
million according to the last promise
thirteen hundred and twenty four million
the difference is 500 million people or
six million dead people per annum in the
years following two thousand
15 now this was done very cleverly the
notion of having world poverty was
maintained but the meaning of that
having of world poverty was changed to
times in order to dilute our promise so
that's important the second point that's
important is that we have to look at
global institutional factors that blow a
head wind against the poor as I said I
give you one more factor reminded by my
colleague over on the other side about
conflict and politics there's a lot of
conflict and a lot of very bad
government in many of the poor countries
one very important reason of that is
that we accept and recognize any person
or group exercising effective power in
one such country as entitled to sell the
natural resources of that country to
borrow money in the name of the country
that the people then have to repay to
sign treaties in the name of the country
and to import weapons in the name of the
country that because they then used to
maintain themselves in power this rule
that we are willing to recognize any
such person or group on the basis of
power alone regardless of how they came
to power and regardless of how they
exercise it is again a very important
factor in explaining why poverty is
persisting despite very nicely rising
average income in the world thank you
lel i guess my final word is that i
believe that the statistics and the
discussion that we've had about the
structures of political economy are
extremely important but when it comes to
spiritual warfare these are important
from the sense of know thy enemy
understand what are the forces that
we're working with that we're attempting
to engage as a pupil of god we need to
be a people of hope and so let's not
allow those statistics and those that
the power of those hurricane winds to
stop us from engaging in to pushing as
in to what are those circles of power
every single one of us in here is
probably
or perhaps two degrees separated from
some extremely powerful people and they
are people there are people who can be
challenged who can be engaged to give to
change the way their corporations run to
change the way their boats go we are all
agents of that change both in our jobs
and our lives and with the people that
we touch because the people on the other
side of the world the people on the
other side of the city or the people
just down the street those people that
were just talking about in the Sudan or
Afghanistan whose schools or fire bond
they are waiting for schools they need
water they need hope they need
opportunities to move forward in life
they don't need us to get paralyzed by
the enormity of our reports or the the
hardship of the path that lies ahead of
us so if we take anything from this
panel let's take energy let's take a
desire to move out as a force to engage
the people that we know with knowledge
and to address the structures okay thank
you for that encouragement and Catherine
final word the moral the ethical
imperative to address these issues of
poverty is something that almost
everyone on this panel has highlighted I
would emphasize that it is both an issue
of caring of the heart and of compassion
but it's also an issue of rights and
justice a question of the correcting the
imbalances in the world to which several
have alluded and even which has not been
very much mentioned here of
self-interest that if these issues of
the vast Gulf and the unfulfilled hopes
of billions in the world are not
addressed there is no security and there
is no safety for any of us are for our
children so we have an ethical
imperative we have
extraordinarily difficult challenge it's
a possible challenge it's a possible
dream but it's one that requires our
intellectual and our organizational
forces we really need to be willing to
deal with the complexity of how you deal
with conflict how you deal with
corruption how you deal with education
systems how you deal with the economies
and finance I want to leave us with two
other issues that that I hope that this
group and the Jew will address in the
future that have not been as much
mentioned in this discussion the first
one and the main dividing issue between
many religious communities and many in
the development community is gender and
the fact that changing relationships
between men and women are really a
revolution of our times and they are
extraordinarily complex and they are
demanding but the Equality of people and
men and women are the largest single
groups is a fundamental principle and it
is one that many have not come to terms
with as to what it means the fact that
there are over a hundred million missing
girls that are not alive because of
neglect or or because of they were they
were eliminated is a telling symbol of
the fact that we are very far from
coming to terms with what gender
equality means and religions play a very
central role in those attitudes for many
different reasons the second issue that
that is beyond the caring about hungry
people about the child who's not in
school is the much more complex issue of
equity and balance so how much inequity
how much inequality is alright how much
how do we balance creativity competition
individual freedom with the enormous
gulfs that are so visible between the
haves and
have nots in our world how do we reflect
how do we bring our intellectual and our
ethical resources to bear I'm thinking
about those problems in a much more
intelligent way in the future so at some
level the poverty issue is more crucial
more important a greater imperative but
in many respects unless we come to terms
with these issues of equity and balance
and fairness it will be difficult to
come to them to the tougher problems of
poverty that are the ones that are still
before us okay thank you glad you
mentioned that first issue of women and
gender equity that's going to be the
subject of the next issue of reflections
as a matter of fact so we will be
following along on some of those
conversations I want to give a word of
thanks to all of the members of the
panel for a stimulating conversation
tonight and I hope it will be useful to
all of you and to all of those who are
going to read and use reflections to
push the conversation along and to do
things with a in meeting some of these
challenges of world poverty we're going
to as a token of our affection and
esteem for the members of the panel give
all of them a little a little gift here
that will we remind them of this night
it should make a nice hanging on their
walls I'm not going to try to give them
out here because it's just too
complicated with all of this panel but
everyone here is going to get one of
these and we're also going to give one
to Joe Donnelly is Joe Donnelly here Joe
please come forward and we'll give you
this give you this one Joe from Caritas
International has been extraordinarily
helpful in setting up the logistics of
this event and he's also been an advisor
to John and ray waddell and the people
who put this magazine together on this
issue and on many others so thank you
very much
let me also say a word of thanks to the
people who put this evening together
first of all 22 ray waddell the editor
of reflections ray take a bow and the
many staff members who were here who put
together the the reception that will
follow momentarily to John lindner and
Connie royster to Gail Briggs a director
of alumni relations he was conning right
here Gail in the back Joanne fan flack
was he earlier is Joanne there is Joanne
and Sandy Lynch came in for the business
side of the the Divinity School to lend
a hand here too so we've had a good team
working on this thank you all for being
here and I look forward to having
conversations with many of you as a does
the panel here as well yes because I
kept my I tried to keep my comments very
short I didn't get to do my advert
advertising art Jubilee USA's website as
WWE USA org and i also have in the back
a sign up chief so we would really
encourage people to sign up